this episode of the live files is
brought to you by the military online
game War Thunder
your world is an illusion your choices
are irrelevant your friends your family
and everyone around you are just
manifestations of your mind your attract
animal in a cage a virtual reality
created more than 250 000 years ago for
a single purpose to use you as food your
emotions are food for those who created
the cage feelings of happiness and joy
are digestible but those emotions are
nowhere near as nourishing as sadness
malice and especially anger pain on a
small scale is good but pain due to war
famine and pandemics well that's even
better you're born you grow and you
spend the first third of your life
learning how to live in a society that
barely knows you exist maybe get married
have kids maybe even grandkids then you
die and the pain ends but death is just
the beginning because now
you get to do it all over again
so only dogs and cats you don't find
home for camels
she is litter trained
there's nothing you can do to help me
I'm kind of in a jam here
did I mention that I have a big YouTube
channel
hello
[Music]
I can't talk alone I need a favor play
why are you Whispering well I'm only at
the beginning and they are already
getting it wrong I have no idea what
you're talking about well mine is stupid
the lace maker I'm a big fan of it Mia
Vermeer I he was a painter
I know who Vermeer is what do you have
to do with The Da Vinci Code yeah
but that little Gill stab I just wanted
to steal my story Danny oh yeah we were
in a creative writing class together one
night after class Danny and I went out
for a few cocktails and I told him about
the time that I solved that murder at
the louva the Louvre it's a museum in
Paris I know what the Louvre is what are
you talking about well I had a few too
many at night and I told Danny how I was
going to write a book about the murder
and how he found all these clues about
the Holy Grail in the night's Templar I
told them everything which was a big
mistake and that nerd can really hold
his liquor Danny you mean Dan Brown
hello is this a bad connection try to
keep up will ya
oh so so I'm on this da Vinci Code
reality tour right at the Louvre
Gathering evidence for my lawsuit
just wait that's so lame at them oh I
think they recognize me who are they and
by the way you're supposed to be here
tomorrow I will be there soon Trace
desolate Madam mom yo we're almost at
the Mona Lisa so I need you to listen
carefully open my laptop and log into
War Thunder I'm in the middle of the new
lab Royale campaign so I need you to
play for me while I get this situation
sorted War Thunder is that today's
sponsor should it coming did you from a
mile away what Thunder is the most
comprehensive highly immersive PVP
vehicle combat game ever made you can
choose from over 2 000 planes helicopter
ships what about tanks I love tanks oh
they got tanks up the Wazoo they're all
super detailed and modeled down to their
individual plants I love tanks I know
you do and I'm not gonna it's getting a
little weird but you can customize your
tank with hundreds of camouflages
well this looks amazing the graphics are
really incredible 4K resolution
authentic sound effects beautiful music
choose from over 100 Years of vehicles
from the 1920s all the way up to today
yeah but what if I want to start my own
campaign you can play War Thunder for
free on PC Xbox One series Exodus and
Playstation 4 and 5. got a link of
course I do I'm a professional
registered PC using the link in the
description and get a large free bonus
pack that includes premium Vehicles
premium account boosters and a lot more
okay look I gotta go next stop is the
Vatican the Supreme pontiff and I have
some unfinished business the pontiff the
Pope I know who the pontiff is anyway
Vatican City isn't in The Da Vinci Code
you're thinking of Angels and Demons
[Music]
the oldest recorded history comes from
ancient Sumerian texts and that's where
we're first introduced to the Anunnaki
the Anunnaki are believed to be seven
deities also referred to as the seven
gods who decree their purpose was to
determine the fate of mankind and their
stories mirror some that we find in
Greek mythology and like the Greek gods
the Anunnaki dwell in the heavens but
also interact with people and influence
events here on Earth Gods from
polytheistic religions like the Anunnaki
the Greek gods and the Roman gods served
many purposes they were used to explain
natural phenomena like Zeus creating
thunderstorms Thor also served this role
in Norse mythology
the gods provided comfort about the
uncertainties of life and questions
about mortality the afterlife and human
suffering
gods and their myths establish social
norms and values myths often included
lessons about the virtues of honesty
courage and wisdom or the danger of
hubris and deceit worshiping Gods who
represent these qualities creates a
framework for social and moral order
gods are part of the creation myth of
many cultures used to explain the origin
of mankind this was also true for the
ancient Sumerians and the Epic of
Gilgamesh written thousands of years ago
the Anunnaki are directly involved in
the creation of humans however the
stories about the Anunnaki might not be
myths the stories might be history
Zechariah sitchin in his book the 12th
Planet claims the Anunnaki are actually
aliens who visited Earth thousands of
years ago from their home planet Nibiru
when they arrived the deity called enki
added alien DNA to Ancient Man and the
result was us
the intention was to create a slave
species to mine gold for the Anunnaki
the gold was refined and used in
terraforming their home planet which was
suffering from a poisoned atmosphere now
this may sound like a far-fetched story
to some but not to me but this creation
Story shows up in other cultures as well
there is an ancient Zulu legend about
two brothers named wawani and impanku
who were from an alien race with scaly
skin
thousands of years ago the brothers
stole an egg from a fire dragon emptied
out the yolk until it was Hollow and
then rolled it across the sky to Earth
that egg was the Moon
[Music]
many ancient texts describe a time when
the moon didn't exist or at least it
didn't exist here Aristotle wrote about
the palestians who lived in ancient
Greece since the oldest days at a time
before the moon apollonius of Rhodes
also talks about a time when the moon
wasn't yet in the sky
in ages past before the silver ore
adorned Knight's somber shroud Gaia
stood alone the tides lay still
Untouched by Luna's grasp and darkness
reigned where Moonlight never cast its
tranquil spell Oh How the Gods conspired
to shape that radiant disc
Greek historian Plutarch wrote about the
arcadians they were a very ancient
people who lived in Greece Plutarch
described them as a pre-lunar people
Rowan poet Ovid also wrote about the
arcadians in Arcadia's Lush Fields where
Pan's flute sang a truth lies hidden
nearly Forgot by man the arcadians are
said to have possessed their land before
the birth of Zeus and the folk is older
than the moon
evidence of a sky with no moon has also
been found on the other side of the
world and the ancient site of tiwanaku
in Bolivia there are symbols that depict
the moon coming into orbit this happened
at a specific Moment In Time thousands
of years ago long before recorded
history according to the Zulu and other
ancient cultures the moon didn't form
the moon was built and not built here
the Zulus say that the moon was built in
another part of the Galaxy by the alien
race the wawani and impaku came from
they built the moon as a monitoring
station to keep an eye on us the human
race but what kind of aliens are
depicted in these old Legends they're
not the small gray aliens the aliens
that built the moon are reptilian
lizard people yup lizard people lizard
lizard lizard lizard better let's go
David Ike has written over 20 books
about various conspiracy theories he's
covered everything from the Illuminati
to UFOs to the Multiverse he's my hero
but he's probably best known for his
theory about a humanoid reptilian race
a theory if it's true do you mind sorry
sorry Lizzy people get me really excited
oh I know
should people cause him out for no I
file store no merge plugs please
Ike claims that humans share the Earth
with a race of shape-shifting reptilian
humanoids called the archons Bomani and
apanku the brothers from the Zulu Legend
who brought the Moon to Earth were
archons the Sumerians call these archon
brothers enki and in Leo who are also
rulers of the Anunnaki this race of
reptilians primarily lives underground
but a few of them live among us as well
the surface dwelling beings are here to
make sure Humanity stays compliant with
and unaware of their plan they're
involved in the highest levels of
government Business and Technology their
monarchs politicians and bankers they
own and operate major media companies
Mark are the allegations true that
you're secretly a lizard
um I'm gonna I'm gonna have to go with
no on that I I am not a lizard
they influence every aspect of human
life they are the Illuminati when we
describe the reptilians as shapeshifters
you might think of a creature sure that
physically changes its shape like Odo
from Star Trek Mystique from Marvel
Comics or Tonks from Harry Potter
reptilians don't do this they actually
always look like themselves what they do
is manipulate the human brain to
perceive them differently the source of
the reptilian's power is their ability
to alter our perception of reality and
they don't do this with telepathy they
do this with technology according to
David Ike the Moon is not only a
spacecraft but also a holographic
projection device the broadcast from the
Moon warp our reality or at least our
perception of reality there's what's
known as a frequency embargo around the
earth
who enforces this
well there's a bunch of alien races who
are part of a Galactic Federation and
they keep an eye on the reptilians but
it's a whole thing
no it needs its own video
this is a bunch of [__] there is
much more to reality than we can
perceive with our senses and the human
brain is quite capable of experiencing
the true Universe in fact it was
specifically designed to do so but the
frequencies that would allow us to see
the real world are being blocked instead
we're locked into the simple
three-dimensional existence but there is
much more being withheld from us if you
believe in simulation Theory then these
beings are the creators of the
simulation if you're religious then
these beings are demons or gin either
way they're not our friends but why why
would an advanced race want to keep
humans oblivious to the real world well
when humans were first created the alien
creators learned something all other
animals on Earth are driven by Instinct
the instinct to eat to survive to
reproduce and that's about it but when
the first humans were given sentience a
byproduct of that sentience was emotion
sure humans are still driven by Instinct
we're driven to survive and reproduce
like every other animal can I get the
guppy support payments to prove it uh
but because humans are now aware of
themselves and their existence they
experience the world differently they
experience fear of the future humans
experience the pleasure of nostalgia for
the past no other animal has this gift
or this curse animals kill for survival
but humans kill out of hate our alien
creators learn that our emotions carry
energy and the creators learn that this
energy can be consumed for nourishment
unfortunately for us negative emotions
are the most nourishing of all
some have described the alien desire for
negative human emotion as a drug
addiction
if humans were able to see and
understand our true reality we know that
our energy or Soul or Spirit or whatever
you want to call it can move to a higher
plane of existence after we die
but instead the alien creators addicted
to our emotions keep us here we're born
we live to feed the creators then we die
then we come back and do it all over
again it's forced reincarnation this
process is handled by a piece of
equipment that's been called a soul
recycler or a Soul Cube which is a large
box-shaped device that's installed on
the moon the cube watches us and then
transmits our energy back to Earth after
we die over and over again and has been
doing so for thousands of years now I
know the theory sounds like science
fiction but many Skeptics were turned
into Believers on December 6 2021 that's
when completely by accident a lunar
probe took a picture of the Soul Cube
[Music]
it's my conclusion
over many years that
that reincarnation
is a trap
it's not that it doesn't exist although
I don't think it's quite the same as
it's explained it's a bit more subtle
maybe but I do think it's a trap
the recycling of souls reincarnation is
the Machinery of this universe
John Lear son of Learjet inventor
billier flew his first flight at age 14.
he became a stunt pilot a contract pilot
for the CIA and set multiple Aviation
records but John lear's most known for
his theories about the alien presence on
Earth he's also exposed a lot of
information about the cube-shaped soul
catcher on the moon
the salt catcher is the what we I think
is the six mile high tower in the middle
of science Medi right in the middle of
the center of the Moon as you look at
the Moon and uh the famous photo that
Richard found a lunar orbiter 384m shows
that huge Tower and he also has two
other photographs that that show that
Tower I think that power is what I call
the soul catcher when you
die your soul is the ghost of the Soul
catcher but the moon isn't the only
place these Soul catchers exist
there are several
Soul uh transmission stations both on
Earth and On The Moon And depending on
where you're going in your next lifetime
uh is which transmission station uh
takes over
when you couple John lear's belief in
the soul catcher with David Ike's theory
that we're stuck in an endless loop of
reincarnation an unsettling reality
emerges that our only purpose is to
serve as food for our alien jailers and
what's even more upsetting is that
negative emotions are really what they
crave supporters of The Reptilian
humanoid Theory say that when there's a
global event that affects millions of
people like a war or major conflict it's
our jailers at work
it might explain why chromanian Homo
sapiens sapien is so violent why are we
always in states of War why are we
competing and always challenged by
murder and violence
I really don't like the idea that we're
not in control of our lives and I really
hate the idea that we're not in control
of our death so my mind just rejects the
idea altogether but then I found this
Soul Cube on the moon
leaping lizards see what it did there
this photo was taken December 6 2021 by
the chinese-made lunar rover u22 while
exploring The Far Side of the Moon a
cube-shaped object is clearly seen 80
meters from the Von Carmen crater and
for some reason the China National Space
Administration labeled this object
mystery Hut this only lends Credence to
the idea that the Moon is a sort of
Observatory with a soul harvesting
machine
there's even more evidence that Earth is
actually what some call a prison planet
in his book humans are not from Earth Dr
Ellis silver contends that humans are
actually from another planet they were
brought here thousands of years ago and
made it with neanderthals the hybrid
species is US my thesis proposes that
mankind did not evolve from native Earth
organisms but evolved elsewhere and was
transported to Earth between 60 000 and
200 000 years ago mankind is supposedly
the most highly developed species on the
planet yet is surprisingly unsuited and
ill-equipped for Earth's environment
the idea that extraterrestrials played a
role in human history is also known as
intervention Theory Dr Silver argues
that if humans actually evolved on Earth
we'd be much more comfortable with the
environment for example humans are
really the only animals that are
susceptible to sunburn
fish reptiles birds all have natural
ultraviolet protection in their scales
and Feathers whales and dolphins have
special skin cells that repair DNA
damaged by UV radiation any mammal with
fur is protected from ultraviolet rays
including Apes if we evolve from apes
why did we lose our hair evolution is
supposed to make us stronger not weaker
and not true for your uncle veto that's
true he's pretty hairy pretty hairy I
bet that guy can open a banana with his
feet Dr Silver points out that human
babies are basically helpless at Birth
they require constant attention for
years or they'll die yes some species of
animals require parental care for a time
after birth but there are plenty of
species that require none insects fish
and most reptiles are born completely
self-sufficient some land mammals are
born standing up some birds are born
with their eyes open and able to find
food on their own no other animal on the
planet is as helpless as we are at Birth
silver claims the reason so many people
have bad backs is that we evolved on a
planet with less gravity that's why as
we age our knees and hips give out we're
not designed to be so heavy we're also
prone to chronic illness more than other
mammals
so why were we brought here in the first
place well silver has a few ideas one is
that humans were brought to Earth as a
natural predator to wipe out other
species now if that's true it worked at
one time there were several different
hominid species living on Earth at the
same time as recently as just forty
thousand years ago neanderthals
denisolvins and at least one other
species coexisted with each other for
several hundred thousand years then
Modern Man arrived and suddenly all
other species were gone
but Dr Silver has another theory that
tracks with a lot of what we've
discussed today but humans were removed
from our natural environment because we
were violent we were destructive and we
over consumed natural resources that
that hasn't changed
the theory said that the aliens erased
our memories so we'd have no
recollection of the civilizations and
Technologies we left behind then they
dropped us off on Earth and left us to
our own devices they watched us for a
while to see how we developed and
eventually they left all the UFO
activity we're seeing now could be our
creators coming to check on their
creation maybe they're checking to see
if we've evolved past our violent
tendencies maybe we're finally ready to
be released from our prison and
reintegrate into Galactic Society if
that's really why they're here then
unfortunately for us our parole
it's going to be denied
foreign
Soul has been pondered well forever
Greek philosophers like Plato and
Socrates proposed an immortal soul that
lives on after the body's death many
religions say the soul originates from
God and exists eternally but the
scientific evidence support the
existence of a soul that can be
Quantified in the early 20th century
physician Duncan McDougall tried to
determine if the soul had measurable
Mass he thought that if a soul existed
it would have weight so upon death the
soul would escape and the weight loss
could be detected McDougall had six
dying patients placed on sensitive
scales finding that they lost an average
of 21 Grams at the moment of death he
concluded this represented the Soul's
Mass but this small sample size and
errors in methodology cast out on the
experiment modern Neuroscience says our
Consciousness and sense of self exist in
our physical brain not a separate Soul
brain Imaging shows that our personality
or memories and cape abilities are tied
to physical patterns and activity within
our neurons damage to certain areas of
the brain through injury or disease can
impact sensory perception Mobility
emotions and even one's identity however
there is an argument that sure the brain
is responsible for cognition and
awareness but a soul could simply be
energy that creates our Consciousness
and if so that Consciousness could
continue after death according to new
theories using quantum physics the soul
may exist in another dimension beyond
our normal space time some tie this to
Quantum non-locality and entanglement
this is where information is passed
between particles not just faster than
the speed of light but instantly no
matter how far apart they are this
Theory says the soul interacts with the
human body through Quantum States
exchanging information instantly across
any distance studies of near-death
experiences provide intriguing reports
of the Soul leaving the body and passing
through a tunnel and encountering
angelic beings or dead relatives yet
Neuroscience says many elements of ndes
are generated by physical brain activity
under stress out of body and near-death
episodes have been induced in controlled
settings by stimulating specific parts
of the brain
conclusive scientific evidence of the
human soul has yet to be discovered
but maybe the soul isn't meant to be
detected with a scale or a microscope or
a computer and just because we can't see
it doesn't mean it's not there religions
around the world say the soul is eternal
in Judaism Christianity and Islam the
soul originates from God and can achieve
eternal life through faith and virtuous
living Hinduism and Sikhism believe the
soul is Immortal and reincarnated based
on Karma Buddhism is a little different
though The Wheel of Life provides a
symbolic map of samsara in Buddhism
Buddhists must attain Enlightenment
before moving beyond this cycle and that
can take many many tries and that's
starting to sound a lot like the soul
recycler and here's something
interesting in the image of the Wheel of
Life which is found on the walls of
monasteries and schools all over the
world Buddha
Buddha is pointing at the Moon
the Moon is the most familiar object in
the night sky it's inspired stories and
myths and even religions the moon has
fueled scientific Intrigue throughout
human history but here's the thing the
Moon is weird by all accounts it
shouldn't even be there
the moon's orbit is extremely close to
the Earth in fact it's the largest moon
in relation to its host planet in our
entire solar system or any solar system
we've never found anything like this in
the galaxy and this proximity has made
total solar eclipses possible this is
because of the precise diameters and
distances between the Sun Moon and Earth
this is an unbelievable coincidence some
might say impossible
there is no astronomical reason why the
moon and the sun should fit so well it
is the sheerest of coincidences and only
the Earth among all the planets is
blessed in this fashion
it's not only too close it's too big
that's what she said
what
using other planets as a reference the
size of the Moon should be about 40
miles in diameter that's it it's over 2
000 miles wide this is also not seen
anywhere else the closest comparison is
Pluto and its Moon Sharon which is about
two-thirds the size of Pluto but this
probably doesn't count because Pluto and
Sharon are a double dwarf planet that's
what she said
what the Earth and Moon are also really
a double Planet but there's something
else strange about that the Barry Center
or center of gravity between the Earth
and Moon is inside the earth that means
there should be a wobble in the moon's
orbit the Moon does wobble a little bit
but its orbit is one of the most
perfectly circular that's ever been seen
the moon is also precisely locked in
orbits so the same side always faces
Earth this is also highly unusual among
moons and planets
some scientists argue that the moon
doesn't wobble because it's not very
dense but that's also a problem if the
Moon and Earth were formed at the same
time which is the leading theory then
why is the earth so much more dense
because the Moon is hollow right
the lunar orbiter experiments vastly
improved our knowledge of the moon's
gravitational field indicating the
frightening possibility that the moon
might be Hollow
in November 1969 Apollo 12 launched as
NASA's second man Mission To The Moon
one of the key objectives was
investigating the moon's interior Apollo
12 astronauts place seismometers on the
lunar surface similar to those used to
detect earthquakes on Earth the
astronauts then intentionally crashed
their Ascent stage module into the moon
to gather seismic data now instead of
typical seismic patterns the data showed
the moon vibrating for over an hour the
moon was famously described as ringing
like a bell the phenomenon LED some to
speculate that the moon might be Hollow
or contain significant Hollow spaces
this theory is supported by the still
classified Apollo 17 project called
Chapel Bell and this sounds like an
experiment that has something to do with
sound but all these years later it's
still classified why
in 1970 two Soviet scientists proposed
that not only is the moon hollow the
Moon is an artificial spacecraft brought
to Earth a long time ago this spaceship
Moon Theory explains many of the
anomalies like the low density the sound
reverberation and why the Moon is even
here at all
spaceship Moon also explains the strange
crater issue Creator issue oh yeah Moon
craters are very odd when an asteroid
impacts a moon or Planet it leaves a
crater the bigger the asteroid the
deeper the crater right yeah I feel you
well on the moon no matter how big the
object that impacts it craters don't
penetrate deeper than a couple of miles
now this could be explained by a rigid
impenetrable outer shell encasing the
moon spaceship Moon
if the astronomical data is reduced it
is found that the data require that the
interior of the moon is less dense than
the outer parts indeed it would seem
that the Moon is more like a hollow than
a homogeneous sphere
data also indicates the moon's core is
less dense than the outer layers the
complete opposite of well every other
celestial object ever discovered this
could be evidence that the moon has vast
Hollow inner cavities also the soil and
moon dust on the surface are actually
older than the Rock and soil within the
Moon that only makes sense if the
interior moon was mined hollowed out and
then the material brought to the surface
now there are scientific explanations
for all of this but to be honest they
fall short looking at all the anomalies
and unanswered questions about the moon
the best explanation for the Moon is an
observational error a it doesn't exist
it's easier to explain the non-existence
of the Moon than its existence we cannot
help but come to the conclusion that the
Moon by rights ought not to be there the
fact that it is is one of those Strokes
of luck almost too good to accept
the Moon is weird it shouldn't be there
and it might be Hollow but is it a
transmission device that affects our
Behavior well there's more crime during
a full moon there are more car accidents
sensitivity to pain is higher during a
full moon a full moon disrupts our sleep
some people are prone to erratic
behavior during a full moon this is
called the werewolf effect this is also
where the word lunatic comes from talk
to a cop or a nurse they'll tell you
that they can tell when it's getting
close to a Full Moon again science tries
to explain this erratic Behavior like
there's more crime during a full moon
because it's easier to see uh no it's
also easier to get caught right the
science is thin and notice that all
these changes in behavior during a full
moon are negative more crime more pain
more car crashes if there are aliens
feeding off our negative emotions and
they use the moon to do it well suddenly
everything makes sense
but there is good news
you can fight back
reptilian humanoid aliens using
technology to alter our reality in order
to create negative emotions our souls
being used for food then recycled over
and over again on the moon
this story is a lot and how much of it
is true well a lot of it depends on your
perspective and what you choose to
believe but let's take it one piece at a
time the Anunnaki are documented in
Sumerian texts but there's plenty of
documentation of Zeus and Apollo and
Athena and the rest of the Greek gods
same with Roman gods Norse gods all gods
really but are any of those gods real
well you decide
interpretations of Sumerian texts have
been largely discredited and disregarded
he's been criticized for inaccurate
translations of the Sumerian Tablets
Skeptics say he manipulated the
translations in order to support his
theory yep it is
true Maybe
but God's coming from the sky creating
man or helping man that story is almost
Universal the Anunnaki are also
connected to the great flood which is a
story found in every culture on Earth
supporters of the Anunnaki Theory claim
that human genetics have traces of alien
DNA the truth is human DNA is pretty
boring our DNA is close to everything on
Earth chimps share almost 99 of their
DNA with humans dogs and cows share
around 80 percent birds and humans share
65 percent of their DNA humans even
share over 50 percent of their DNA with
bananas you're related to a banana yep
maybe that's why you got appeal
[Music]
Dr Ellis Silver's theory that humans
didn't originate on Earth is really
interesting he lays out a lot of
scientific evidence to support this
Theory but even he admits the theory has
some holes and he's released updates to
try and fill in some of these holes
still mainstream science rejects the
idea that humans originated on a
different planet
but there is a wrinkle in 2020
researchers discovered that about 50 000
years ago ancient humans procreated with
a species that scientists didn't know
existed they call this ghost DNA and the
timing lines up perfectly with Dr
Silver's Theory his book is amazing and
I'd love to do a full episode on how
humans might have been transported here
so if you'd like to see that let me know
that will be a wild ride
now let's talk lizard people lizard
lizard lizard lizard better
the most well-known proponent of The
Reptilian conspiracy is David Ike my
hero David Ike is well read well spoken
and highly entertaining his histories
are extremely creative but like most
conspiracy theories you can't prove or
disprove him
but remember in 1991 he claimed to be
the Son of God and the world was going
to end and he made this claim on
television while wearing a turquoise
tracksuit
you do claim to be the Son of God oh
come on Heroes wear track suits the
lizard people story seems to have
started in 1934 with an LA Times article
a mining engineer claimed to have found
tunnels underneath Los Angeles a Hopi
Indian told him the legend of the lizard
people who are an advanced race that
escaped through the tunnels 5000 years
ago well that's why so many movies does
a shape-shifting lizard people
easy commute uh maybe but there are no
tunnels and there is no Hopey legend of
the lizard people so uh I don't believe
that one and honestly when I started
this topic I didn't believe any of it
well except for the moon stuff the the
Moon is weird
but while researching I found myself
bouncing between feelings of depression
and fear and anxiety and especially
anger the message boards blogs comment
sections I came across are filled with
people expressing outrage they're
Furious that they have us all trapped in
this never-ending Loop of misery that we
are made to endure this torturous unfair
life time and time again we're not given
a choice to come back or not our only
purpose is to be food for our prison
guards but if they truly believe that an
advanced race is feeding offer negative
emotions well they're giving our jailers
exactly what they want there are so many
comments that were blame seeking I saw a
lot of people with a self-centered
victim mentality it was frustrating to
read but I understand it life is hard
life is unpredictable and life is
painful when things in life go wrong
it's easy to shift responsibility to a
theoretical they instead of looking in
the mirror David Ike John Lear and
others who promote The Reptilian
conspiracy say that we don't have to
exist in an endless cycle of pain and
reincarnation negative emotions fuel the
cycle positive emotions can break it so
you have a choice you can choose to be
the change choose kindness over anger
choose acceptance over judgment and
choose gratitude over the endless desire
for more choose Joy over sadness and
mercy over Revenge just choose love or
hate now I know it's not easy I really I
really do but your life really can be
whatever you want it to be the choice
is yours
registered PC using the link in the
description and get a large free bonus
pack that includes premium Vehicles
premium account boosters and a lot more
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ and that's cycle
fish what's the word sexy dude this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything do us a favor like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps and like most topics we
cover on the channel today's topic is
recommended by you so if there's a store
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to yfiles.com tips now if you need more
Wi-Fi's in your life check out the white
files Discord there's thousands of
people on there 24 7 and they're all a
little bit weird like we are and special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible you guys are the heart
of the channel and I couldn't do this
without you now if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon for as little as three
dollars a month you get all kinds of
perks special access on Discord Early
Access to videos without commercials
Early Access to fun products like the
Heckle fish talking plushie and two
extra live streams a week just for you
but if you'd rather get something for
your money I get it check out the Wi-Fi
store
[Music]
I promise the plushies will not Harvest
your soul well that's a relief I put
they will harvest about 30 bucks well
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind I know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
a secret code inside the Bible said I
was
I love my UFOs and paranormal buns as
well as music songs
[Music]
conspiracy theory becomes the truth my
friends and it never ends I know it
never ends
[Music]
I fear the crap Daddy I got stuck inside
Mel's home with them chaos
[Music]
did Stanley Kubrick fake the moon
landing alone on a film chat I wear the
Shadows before
[Music]
and his name was cold
all I ever wanted was to give me
[Music]
the map Man sightings and the solar
storm still come to have got the secret
City Underground
spout
[Music]
Ure
oh
yeah
[Music]
thank you